[Music]
so
the most valuable possession the nation
has
is the health of its people
a country without a healthy population
cannot grow and advance
in most latin american countries
a shortage of health personnel
especially doctors
and geographic obstacles that make
access to remote areas difficult
have created a lack of adequate health
assistance for the great number of
people
[Music]
to alleviate this situation
the universidad del valle in cali
colombia has developed a health system
that incorporates many innovations
one of these is the training of
non-medical personnel
to perform most of the routine although
important activities
thus allowing the doctors and graduate
nurses to devote more time on serious
cases
this system focuses on the health of the
mother and child
protecting the child during its vital
cycle
from the very moment it is conceived
[Music]
colombia is a country of sharp contrasts
and vast resources
its 22 million inhabitants have the same
health problems as the people of other
latin american countries
in 1958
the universidad del valle chose
candelaria as the experimental center of
training for the personnel
that now form a new system of health
services
candelaria located only 30 kilometers
that is 19 miles away from kali
has a total rural and urban population
of thirty thousand
its proximity to the universidad del
valle made it the ideal spot for the
project
members of the community are in charge
of many of the services offered by the
system
over 90 of the population is covered by
this health system
which is centrifugal in nature that is
to say
instead of waiting for the patients to
come for help
health personnel will visit their homes
periodically
in this manner the home becomes the
first level of medical attention
for the individual
and the family
it's an advantage i no longer have to
take my kids to the center
the aids come visit us instead
[Music]
dr emilio alhure
former dean of the health division of
the universidad del valle mentions a few
of the goals of this system
among the different educational programs
of this university
and resources of health in this area
we would like to collaborate with other
health promoting agencies and
institutions
in the search of solutions to these
problems
we are also dedicated
to the training of personnel for the
health system
particularly to make innovations that
will increase the efficiency of this
training
the efficiency of a health system
depends on its personnel
in this case the system consists of
medical students and graduate nurses
they in turn
are assisted by non-medical personnel
promoters midwives
and auxiliary nurses
the promoters are two-year volunteers
young girls from the community who have
finished at least their elementary
school education
and feel motivated to help other members
of the community
during these two years you will not
received any kind of salary
the work is called voluntary because you
don't get paid a nickel
after they are selected by the graduate
nurse the girls receive an enabling
course which lasts six to eight weeks
and is followed by a period of practical
training
the responsibilities of the promoter are
to identify pregnancies early in the
woman's term
control the growth and nutrition of the
child
provide immunization
inform the couple about family planning
programs available through the health
system
report to the auxiliary nurse the
results of the visits
which happen every two months
and finally collect information about
important facts
mobility
and use of health services
the midwives are women from the
community who have been performing birth
assistance at patients homes for years
the system has grouped and registered
them
keeping an accurate record of their
activities
first the nurse and the auxiliary take a
census of midwives to be trained and
enrolled in the health team
where they will have to comply with
specific rules on child birth services
the midwives must report the births they
have attended within 24 hours
this allows the auxiliary nurse to make
her postnatal visit within 48 hours of
the birth
much of the midwives knowledge has been
passed down from mother to daughter for
generations
the auxiliary nurse is a very important
element in the health system
with the equivalent of at least two
years of high school education
who receive a formal 12-month course in
the school for medical auxiliaries
the auxiliary nurses train promoters
diagnose pregnancies
take care of prenatal control at home
attend medium medium-risk births at the
health center
give instructions on the use of health
cards
supervise promoters and midwives
take care of postnatal control
[Music]
give family planning information and
advice
and refer serious cases to the doctor
the unit responsible for the program
consists of one doctor and one graduate
nurse
they are in charge of programming and
supervising the complete system as well
as solving the medical and
administrative problems sent by the
other units
these are some of the many persons
responsible for the new health system in
candelaria
people whose goal is to offer better
health to the individual
the
family and the community
people with very good reasons to be
optimistic about their work
for in the last 10 years infant
mortality in candelaria has dropped 65
percent
and contagious diseases have diminished
considerably
all of these people function within the
following scheme of health service
levels which are
house
health post
health center
university hospital
[Music]
for each one of these levels
there has been assigned
the required personnel
the activities to be developed
geographic area and population to be
covered
the transferring mechanisms
[Music]
a valuable tool in the system is the
health card
containing the clinical history of each
child
growth control
nutrition
immunization instructions
diagnosis and important treatments
and identification data
in the near future this card will
include a health calendar and a record
for pregnant women
the system emphasizes the health of the
pregnant woman and the fetus
it is known that a child born under
unhealthy conditions
has very few probabilities of survival
[Music]
the expectant mother when diagnosed by
the promoter receives in her home
the periodic visit of the auxiliary
nurse
according to her previous medical
history and the development of her
pregnancy
the auxiliary nurse will in time
determine where the woman will receive
her prenatal care and birth assistance
thus at the home
the auxiliary will
verify pregnancy
classify pregnancy risks
control low risk pregnancies
referring medium and high risk
pregnancies
take samples for routine tests
instruct on pregnancy childbirth and
care of the newborn
these services can be given either at
the patient's home by the auxiliary
nurse and midwives
at the health center by the auxiliary
nurse and the general doctor
or at the hospital by the specialist
the auxiliary nurse also makes
recommendations regarding nutritional
diets
instructs the woman about necessary
hygiene and care of the newly born
and informs her of the importance of
family planning
if during one of her visits the
auxiliary nurse encounters a case that
is not within her capacity to solve
she refers it to the doctor
approximately 60 of the births are
attended at home by midwives
35 at the health center
and less than five percent need the care
of the specialist
the first year in the life of a child is
critical in its struggle for survival
so it is important that the auxiliary
nurse visits the home of the new mother
within 48 hours after the birth
after assisting in a childbirth the
midwife should inform the auxiliary
nurse within a 48-hour period
the auxiliary nurse then examines the
mother and the child
to see if the midwife has complied with
all aspects of the program
the health system covers 90 percent of
the population
so it does have an advantage over the
traditional system
it has been possible therefore in
candelaria
to quickly diagnose
to give an adequate treatment to all
serious pregnancy complications
both prenatal and postpartum
and to achieve a significant decrease
in maternal death rate
following childbirth the auxiliary nurse
informs the mother about family planning
services
instruction through short-term courses
introduction of method by the health
center physician
and continued attention by the auxiliary
of the health problems
i started
planning after my fourth child
i was given an appointment
and went to a meeting where we here
learn how this family planning was
a new health system through the
promoters and auxiliary nurses
inform the women about the availability
of family planning
now in candelaria 90 of the couples know
about the program
and 35 are using the method offered
the birth rate has dropped 33 in the
last 10 years
and the rate of abortion has diminished
30 percent
since the initiation of the program in
1965.
[Music]
birth control methods are new things
here
and many patients have heard about side
effects that may result from their use
[Music]
often these patients want to know
whether it is true that iuds cause
cancer
produce pain
or become difficult
[Music]
[Music]
the auxiliary answers the questions
honestly
removing these fears often by relating
examples of other satisfied patients
women who have used iuds successfully
for years
then desire
and gave birth to a healthy baby
situation
in some cases too many children may be
dangerous for the health of the mother
and the stability of the family
existing
and health services
cannot keep up with the ever-increasing
population
and emotional welfare of the entire
family
is that if i have a larger family i
could not have both a place to live
would not have
it would not be enough to support them
the well-being of the child and the
family
is the ever-present preoccupation of
those who work for the welfare of the
community
in addition to the health of the mother
the system places much emphasis on
caring for the child
care of the child during its first five
years of life is of utmost importance
considering that 50 percent of the
deaths in colombia and other latin
american countries occurred during this
period
from the first time the auxiliary nurse
visits the newly born until he is five
years old
the child will be visited at home every
two months by the promoters
and will be sent to the doctor at the
health center whenever the conditions
require it
on the child's health card the promoters
will note the stage of development at
each visit the promoters will report any
deviations to the auxiliary nurse
and the doctor will immediately attend
to it
at the home the promoter will
guide growth and nutrition
administer immunizations
control diarrheas
instruct on health care
and refer patients when additional
attention is required
the promoter will inform the auxiliary
nurse of undernourished children
the nurse will then reinforce the need
for nutritional education at the family
home
the auxiliary nurses educate mothers on
the subject of nutritional values and on
preparing food for the children
nutrition is a very important aspect in
the development of a child
it has been demonstrated that
malnutrition can produce mental
retardation
it is important to point out that in
candelaria severe forms of malnutrition
have been eliminated
and only some light and moderate cases
of retardation
appear today
in seven years malnutrition has dropped
from 40 percent to 20
an important figure
since a national survey in 1966 revealed
that malnutrition affected 50 of the
children under 5 years of age in
colombia
when a child has malnutrition symptoms
the auxiliary nurse refers the case to
the doctor
the physician at the health center takes
care of the cases by giving the
necessary prescriptions and
recommendations
when the problem cannot be solved at
this level
the physician refers the patient to the
hospital
the health card also indicates when the
child should receive the immunizations
offered by the program
all children are vaccinated against
smallpox
tetanus
whooping cough
diphtheria
tuberculosis
and polio
measles immunization will also be
provided in the future
the lives of many children have been
saved
thanks to preventive immunization
attention to good dental health is given
high importance
this service is performed by the
auxiliary nurses
they are able to perform fluoride
applications and other treatments
previously done
only by medical personnel
this is yet another example of how
non-professional personnel
properly trained and supervised
can assist in solving important problems
the new health system provides other
services for the community
such as epidemiological research for
control and treatment of tuberculosis
rabies
malaria
leprosy
and other communicable diseases
in the control of these diseases
techniques are available not only for
diagnosis and treatment
but also to raise the resistance level
of the population
[Music]
the system also offers medical and
hospital care for school-aged children
and for adults as they are needed
[Music]
later innovations will be introduced in
the health services given to these
groups
almost 50 percent of latin america has
sanitation problems
water used for washing and cooking must
be free of bacteria and other
microorganisms
which produce gastrointestinal diseases
skin infections
and other illnesses
good health does not imply only the
absence of disease
the world health organization describes
health
as an absolute state of physical mental
and social well-being
[Music]
new sanitation measures and innovative
health systems such as the one developed
at the universidad del valle
are one more step
for the achievement of a better life
[Applause]
the environmental sanitation program in
candelaria
includes the construction of water and
sewer facilities through community
action and government support
the program offers technical assistance
and with this system
ninety eight percent of the urban homes
today
have drinking water and sewage services
ten years ago this was true for only
forty percent of the homes
the environmental sanitation program
also controls food and garbage disposal
and provides education on personal and
home hygiene
the quality of any system depends
greatly on the preparation of the
professionals who will direct it in the
future
this is why the universidad del valle
exposes its medical students to early
contacts with the communities
where they will be working
a close relationship between the future
doctor and the area where his knowledge
will be used
will produce a higher interest and
motivation in the young professional
among other activities they also will
participate in the training
and supervision of midwives
to leave this impression
with
we could go on working integrated with
the community
and not overlooking this reality
we want to leave that impression
the children who are cared for through
an integral health program
will grow strong
and will be able in the future
to put their healthy minds and energy to
work for the development and welfare of
their nations
the universidad del valle hopes to
obtain the same success in the
metropolitan area of cali and has
selected the community of union de
viviende popular popular housing union
with 100 000 inhabitants to establish
the same system
in this way it is hoped
that similar problems in other colombian
and latin american areas
can be solved
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you